the fda says it is working on solutions
to end this country's worsening shortage
of baby formulas parents scramble to get
supplies the out-of-stock average for
baby formula nationwide jumped to 43
percent just last week now in november
that number was only 11 percent big
difference there we are now seeing empty
store shelves and months long wait for
the products that your babies need janet
shamley and spoke to a family struggling
to deal with the shortages
for taylor and kenny miller every drop
of formula counts
the katy texas couple is rationing it
for their four-month-old daughter
magnolia
how many stores have you had to go to to
find the formula you need
i lost count you've lost count yes
that many yes that many we'll literally
waste a whole tank of gas in a day
trying to find formula and maybe only
find one can the couple has just over
four cans left a two-week supply how
much of a stressor is this for you it's
very stressful i mean the other day i
actually found formula and i bought all
the cans and i feel like a bad person
but my kids got to survive it's a
nationwide problem in at least five
states more than 50 percent of sellers
are out of stock
25 states and dc are between 40 and 50
percent empty up from seven states just
a few weeks ago there's family in
louisiana
i had some friends in georgia and
tennessee look we have family in
delaware literally coast to coast and
nobody has found anything with empty
shells becoming the norm sellers are
limiting purchases to help stabilize
inventory a february recall by
manufacturer abbott laboratories
contributed to the national shortage but
experts say supply chain issues also
played a role now the average cost of
the most popular baby formula products
is up as much as 18 percent over the
last 12 months
our biggest fear is that parents dilute
the formula and this is a big no-no dr
diane hess is a pediatrician at new york
city's gramercy hospital
she and the fda are warning parents
against making formula themselves that's
how babies end up having seizures or
dying or becoming malnourished because
most of those recipes are outdated and
they could be dangerous and they're not
scientifically based a crisis parents
hope ends quickly for cbs morning's
janet chameleon houston
so you can tell first hand yeah it's
terrifying
we are not we are not wasting a drop now
i used to always take four ounces at
night i used to put five in the bottle
in case she was hungry no more like we
are in conservation mode at this point
because we know there's no more if we
run out has to be scary for new parents
yeah yeah and people say oh mother's
milk is free but you know some women
can't breastfeed other women are going
back to work and they have jobs because
they got to make money to pay for
everything else
it doesn't suit them and the milk
doesn't always flow either
as a nursing mom it doesn't it's not as
easy as you may think it is big problem
in this country one of many